survivor of child sexual abuse is
working to pass a law requiring abuse
prevention classes in all public schools
studies reveal that one in four girls
and one in six boys are sexually abused
before the age of 18 Erin's law named
after Aaron Marin has passed in 36
states and it is pending now in 14
additional states actress julianna
margulies has pushed lawmakers for years
to pass the law in her home state of New
York
Lena 9 and visited a school in Illinois
to see how the classes teach kids about
safe and unsafe touches I think you
shouldn't be afraid to talk about just
two kids what sexual abuse is and how to
stop it and look out for it's hard to
believe that this young group of 4th 5th
and 6th graders can speak about child
sexual abuse with such candor a lot of
the times that goes unreported because
people are scared it could happen to my
brother it could happen to me it can
happen to my friends it can be even like
people you know and that you trust can
do it that's like scary how many of you
have heard about child sexual abuse just
before sitting down with us these
students were taught a 50-minute child
safety class do not touch me were they
learned about how to prevent recognize
and respond to bullying emotional and
sexual abuse what is it that you think
will stay with you after you leave the
classroom if someone tries to touch you
in a place that you don't feel
comfortable and come and tell me you
should tell an adult and don't be afraid
to speak up
the program is in what Keegan Illinois
it's part of a statewide mandate
requiring students be taught personal
body safety it's known as Aaron's law
and is currently in 36 states
kindergarten to 12th grade we must spend
an hour out of a school year t getting
the law passed and those 14 pending
states including New York is Aaron
Moran's mission I will come back until
this law is passed and she's had a
longtime support from actress julianna
margulies Aaron I was once that six year
old that woke up at the overnight at my
best friend's house to her uncle's
sexually abusing me telling me to keep
it a secret and so I didn't tell I was
frightened I was terrified she woke me
up to a real epidemic
I was never sexually abused as a child
and I just kind of bowled me over only
20% of adult females and five to ten
percent of adult males recall a
childhood sexual assault or sexual abuse
incident and report it I think there's
so much shame attached to it and it's
this old ridiculous adage of well what
were you wearing
maybe you asked to be raped that kind of
attitude toward the fact that we might
be physically a weaker sex and children
are physically boys and girls weaker
than adults that doesn't mean anyone has
the privilege to abuse that what do you
say to parents who say I want it to be
my decision how much and when and where
I teach my kids about sexual abuse I
tried to explain to parents this is
personal body safety this is teaching
kids the difference between safe and
unsafe touch safe and unsafe secrets who
are five safe adults you can go to if
something is happening to you you know
safe defense class yeah self-defense
class how they should look at it and
what keeps me going is continuing to see
these stories of another child
disclosing that they have been abused
immediately after being taught Aaron's
law that was the case with Lisa Jesse's
daughter it's not something that you
ever expect your child to them home and
say whoa this is what happened
she believes Aaron's law helped her
daughter come forward when she was 10
years old my daughter came home and just
immediately told me I was
inappropriately touched this was your
child's biological father
where is he now he's in prison for the
next 11 years for people who say that
this program is too controversial and
shouldn't beat on schools what do you
say it's such a good thing for the kids
to be comfortable because it gives them
control that's exactly what we witnessed
with these kids how many of you feel
other schools in this country should
have a course like this without a doubt
without a doubt yes
the bill has died in New York's
legislature every year before a vote
could even take place supporters hope it
will be voted on this year before the
end of the session that would be in
mid-june that's a powerful piece by our
Trina 9 in yes and a powerful advocacy
by julianna margulies didn't get it
right the first time I apologize for
that well we knew what you met Mina
Richmond I love what Julie and I said
though that you should think of it as
self-defense for your children it's
empowering for kids really is all
parents want their kids to be safe so to
give them the language and the boys and
how to do it and where to do it
I think is very very strong thank you to
Aaron and Juliana both very important